hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff and the moment you've all
been waiting for it's the finals of the
first American chess congress in 1857
poll trials more filled with the white
pieces in game 1 against Louie Paulson
now so far both of them had a brilliant
winning streak both of them 9 wins 0
losses and only one draw and now of
course they face each other so far two
of them played four games one game did
was show we've shown it was a blindfold
simultaneous game which Morphy one as he
was one of the contestants in a
simultaneous game that Paulson was
holding then there are two other blind
four games that they played one game was
won by Murphy one game was drawn and
then there is one more game that was not
recorded we do not have records of these
moves the dead game also ended in a draw
they say maybe it was never recorded
maybe the moves just weren't published
but who knows you know maybe maybe
someday someone decides who has these
moves that he wants to publish them and
then we're gonna have that as well but
so far we don't so this is a basically
50 game a game between the two of them
but the first game of the actual
American chess congress so without
further ado let's check it out
more feet with the white pieces opens
with E for as he usually does we have c5
by Paulsen going for the Sicilian
defense and now the immediate the d4 so
see captures on d4 and not one more if
he could go for some c3 gambit upon this
way he just goes in Knight to f3 and
then he will decide whatever was in
place maybe he will transpose into the
normal Sicilian or play something else
maybe c3 Bishop c4 and so on so we have
ecigs by Paulsen very strongly reply and
not just Knight captures on b6 just
transposing into the normal Sicilian
Bishop to c5 now putting pressure on the
night and the night the b3 attacking the
bishop push it back to b6 and Knight to
c3
so Murphy has two knights out and the
Posen has this very nice Bishop with
Knight to e7 by Paulsen now already the
Castle f5 and the d5 might be might be
ideas in the future and more if he goes
for Bishop to f4 and it's a it's a
really nice idea by more human
so develop the queen he wants to maybe
Castle queenside maybe maybe develop the
banking side but what Paulsen definitely
needs to do is play d5 here it's
something we often say when we show as a
Sicilian game if your opponent allows
you to push d5 you you push d5 because
you know it next move might be too late
so instead of the five Paulsen Castle
here probably thinking he's gonna play
d5 the next move but here Morphy says no
you won't he just plays Bishop to d6 and
now how how will pause and ever play d5
that's the question so instead of d5
morphia strikes in the center with f5 as
more of his Kingston in the center of
the board it does make sense to open up
some lines with E 5 by Murphy again a
principled idea not allowing to open
lines and there are some modern games
where Nightbeat the c6 was played and
even where f4 was played but after a six
we reach a position that was never
reached again after this game in 1857
so morphing continues development we
have Bishop to e2 and night beat the c6
now we castles by Murphy and rook to f7
now this is a very annoying pin you
can't move the night so rook to f7 and
now kink the h1 Morphy also wants to
start pushing his F pawn and due to the
pin he's not able to so King h1 he wants
to play maybe some like f4 maybe after I
for bringing a rook lift maybe look
every to g3 and get the rook into the
attack so Paulson prevents it with f4 he
says no you don't but you can't just
take something without giving something
so here by taking more space on the
Kings side you no longer control the e4
square and this is exactly what Murphy
it uses Knight to e4 now with an
excellent square for his knight Knight
to f5 pause and also free DF 5 square
for his knight now putting pressure on
Murphy's Bishop here but Murphy just
continues Bishop h5 attacks the root we
have g6
pushing back more fees Bishop and Bishop
to g4 now saying okay yeah you could
capture my bishop here but if you do I'm
just gonna get an even better Square for
my knight and it's gonna be a really
tough position to play
and although okay maybe after okay faith
you can maybe develop your queen to g4
maybe to h4 but it's a hard to imagine
that something good can come of it
so instead Paulson decides that he wants
to go about it the other way he goes a
night back to g7 and she wants to start
pushing on the King side now with h5h
4g5 and so on so Queen to f3 buy
morphine and now h5 with the ship to h3
and now Queen to h4 here planning now g5
and g4 but more fee of course doesn't
allow it he plays Knight to f6 with
check King h8 and now Quinta efore
putting pressure on the e under g6 pawn
here we have Queen to g5 defending and
now g3 and here with this g3 move what
morph is saying I'm either gonna open up
the G file and then use the G file for
my rooks which would be which would be
great since I would get access to the g6
pawn and if you if you capture then I
get a nice open F file or maybe maybe I
can then even put my my Rocksteady G
file okay due to the bishop slicing over
this way probably not but still I would
get the open F file maybe I can double
Rock sandhya file and it's still unclear
how are you how honored how are you
going to develop your light-square
bishop and get this rock into the game
so for now it's as if more fees down to
pieces well a piece and the rook at
least until he figures out a way how to
get them into the game with f3
sorry f3 by Paulsen not not allowing the
opening of any files and he says that
okay if you capture with the Queen then
I have Knight captures here and then I
just you lose the defender of the night
and have sex and if you capture it's
just much much better for fall so now as
the night will fall as well so instead
morphe says ok my queen is gonna keep
the defending the d5 pawn along with the
bishop and I go for the f3 pawn with the
knight Knight d2 with Bishop to d8 now
there's nothing you can do about the
ponceau Bishop to b8 now putting more
pressure on the night here Knight
captures on f3 first with an attack on
the Queen Queen to h6 and now a silent
but deadly moved by morphe rooked
g1 and you'll see you'll see why why why
it's such a nice move
we have Bishop characters and f6e
captures an f6 and now not recapturing
right away but first night the e8
putting pressure on the bishop and also
ready to recapture the pawn and the next
move with Bishop to f4 attacking
attacking Posen's Queen and now comes
Knight captures on f6 by Paulsen he says
okay you capture here I'm gonna capture
your queen on e4 but this doesn't work
because they were very very well a very
clear reason so feel free to pause the
video and try to find why it doesn't
work
and how does more if you win this game
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that you are
able to win a piece here and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
its Queen captures and c6 and it's
actually well it is clear now that you
see it point is that if you recapture
then just Bishop captures the Queen and
your upper piece because you just want a
piece and c6 so this is not possible for
Paulsen Paulsen has to play Queen
captures on f4 another idea now of
course if characters just captures but
now more if he continues with Queen
captures and c8 and this comes with
check so first Paulsen has to recapture
and only then will more if you recapture
the Queen and he will be up a piece so
rook captures G captures on f4 and now
after all is said and done more fees up
a piece and now his rook occupies the
beautiful semi-open G file which will do
go a long way the night is coming to e5
and it's just very hard for Paulsen to
continue playing this but what what
insight on morph is part playing rook to
g1 now the rook occupying such a
beautiful beautiful file you'll just see
what happens rook captures and c2 now
Paulsen is down material he really needs
to win back some material if you can
gobble up some of these pawns then maybe
maybe he can even start pushing and and
well try find some compensation for the
piece although very unlikely rook ate
the c1 Murphy says okay wheeler trade
which is of course favorable to me as
I'm up material
or you move the rook and then I get my
rook to see it and grab even more
activity rook captures an f2 is played
by Paulson
but now rope the c8 with check we have
Knight to g8 blocking and now Knight to
e5 threatening to just pick up the g6
pawn with check we have looked the g7
but it doesn't really help Knight
captures on g6 with check King h7 and
now Knight back to f8 with check King to
h6 and now Knight captures on d7 saying
okay if you want to trade here it's okay
rook captures put put pressure on your
rook after you move the rook I just play
Bishop captures here and it's game over
I'm still up a piece and nothing is
stopping these this past pawn all of
these squares are covered by my bishop
in the night so it's it's it's free free
running forward for my passport so after
Knight captures on d7 we have rook
captures on d7 and now rook C captures
on g8 and now there's not much you can
do here Paulsen grabbed a bit more
material he played rook captures on f4
but now Bishop captures on e6 grabbing
the pawn attacking the rook we ripped
the e7 attacking the bishop but it was
also in this position unmoved 36 that
Louis posin resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here it's
actually a forced meeting in four moves
but I'm not gonna show it to you before
you pause the video and try to find it
for ourselves while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the the nice mate in four and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook 8 the g8 to g6 check
your free bg8 square for your bishop
there's only one move for the black King
King to h7 and now Bishop the g8 with
check King h8 only move and now rook the
h6 with check the bishop is defended by
the rook so there's only one move rook
to h7 and now rogue characters and h7 is
made and that's matin for so yeah like I
said after rook to e7
Paulson resigned and after five and a
half hours of playing the game the game
ended and the first game of their match
goes to Paul Morphy and even though it's
the finals it's still best of
so whoever whoever comes on top so yeah
really really impressive stuff by Murphy
and also very instructive after this
Bishop to f4 was played like I said
whenever you get a chance to play d5 in
the Sicilian if white allows it play it
because well maybe even as of next move
like you've seen in this game you will
not be able to play it for the rest of
the game which is what happened here and
it costs Paulson dearly
so we'll see what Paulson learned from
this game and will he be able to apply
it somehow differently in in the rest of
the match or will he maybe like like
more fees previous opponent maybe try to
take the battle not maybe into open
games semi open games but maybe into
close games and close positions because
maybe they're more field will not be
able to shine as bright as he does in
open positions so like I said five and a
half hours of great play but other games
will will last even longer and this is
going to be somewhat of a problem which
but we're going to talk about that in
the rest of the Morphy saga so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Morten restore
Jonathan Owen John Austin Begum impacts
srl and Elias Tahu for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Morphy saga continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and of course whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend